si tu savais olala qu'il dit tu alors si
tu savais ah bon alors j'aurais voulu
que tu avoir au moins aussi joué c'était
une femme unique la mienne aussi était
unique
elle avait une peau ou d'ananas les
dessins ou d'année un homme rien qu'en
voyant ses yeux on sentait qu'elle avait
de jolies jambes
rien qu'en voyant ses jambes on sentait
qu'elle allait aux yeux et son sourire
angélique diabolique ont changé en main
oui quand il sortait du bain et et la
vénus de milo ilm avec tes bras c'est la
victoire de samothrace sans les ailes
mais avec sa tête
franchement
honnêtement il y en avait pas deux comme
elle je l'avais rencontré en novembre
un tiens c'est curieux moi aussi quand
une soirée sans joie mais c'était le
matin mais c'était compliqué et pourtant
pour moi tout à coup ce fut avril
normand ce fut carrément en juillet mais
il faut dire que j'aime la chaleur
duquel m'est apparu j'ai fait ah ah bah
c'est curieux moi j'ai fait ou un non
mais c'était le café aux as et moi
c'était le cas faire l'union après l'été
dans mes bras et moi dans les siens on
s'est embrassés longtemps très longtemps
dans l'eau perdre le souffle à en perdre
la tête en oublier le temps en payer
tout oui tout
sauf tout de même de prendre rendez-vous
pour le lendemain bien entendu année dit
ah non moi minuit je suis un couche-tard
a est alors la fait pas à merveille
extraordinaire éblouissant
l'étourdissant enivrant exaltant
sensationnel exceptionnelle en hameaux
veux tu que je te dise inqualifiable non
franchement honnêtement il n'y en avait
pas de calais et puis je les revues tous
les jours moi toutes les nuits elle me
disait que j'étais sans soleil mois sans
étoile densément la nuit oui ça se
comprend
elle avait toutes les qualités toutes
les perfections elle me disait que
j'étais le premier que là mais à ce
point moi je serais le dernier qu'elle
et moi est ainsi était aussi doué pour
la cuisine que pour l'amour c'est pas
près d'oublier nuti souper aux
chandelles ont la grande cheminée où
crépite elf doit même one au déjeuner
d'amour près de sa fenêtre fleurie comme
celle de mimi pinson
j'aimais autant ses mains de fée que que
sa tête de vous et moi sa cuisse de
nymphe que ses pieds année
non franchement honnêtement j'en avais
pas deux comme elle et puis un jour
brusquement la disparue oui la mienne
aussi a disparu brusquement sans donner
la moindre explication au moi non plus
et sans me laisser d adresse
je passe souvent devant son appartement
au mois au 6 rue des deux ponts
quels écueils elle habitait rue des
deux-ponts la mienne aussi au 2o donné
deux coups au deuxième poteau vienne
porte unique unique
eh ben mon vieux tu vois
arthur on avait raison il y en avait
vraiment pas deux comme elle santé